okay for people joining this live stream
we are talking about
topic of elegant code formatting
and
we've been looking at uh
well
providing at least an elegant option for
code formatting and possibly changing
the default
uh
so I can't even tell if this is minus
based or not is this monospaced
the text part's not no that it's tagged
as model space so that the operators are
but no this is the new font
you know the fact that I can't even tell
I know
see what John thinks of that but I agree
with you
John
uh
I tip what do you want me to say you can
tell it is modest place like it I I can
absolutely tell yeah absolutely yes
okay
um
but you know the fact that operators are
are much closer to being monospace and
it makes a difference but yes I can
absolutely tell nonetheless but so John
the tweaks from last time this added
some letter spacing which actually fixed
these tight
spaces between operators and text in
some cases so I think we're much closer
to monospace than we were last week
line spacing is a little better font
size is a little better but if you put
this next to a normal notebook
it's fairly similar with just better
type sorry I I haven't looked at your
notebook are you saying that that you
you actually tweaked the space to try to
yeah I gave it so letter spacing I
forget the option but but it actually
helped a lot with some of the issues we
saw last week okay okay so this is not
something that you're getting for free
from the font at this point no no it's a
front end okay okay although you might
want that but yeah yeah
the space before the opening square
bracket of a function is still a little
bit too large for my taste
not there
yeah I mean those you know we pad
operators as I think most people here
know uh the the padding is different
depending on the operator so like left
and right brackets are padded uh you
know
mirrored to each other uh in terms of
left and right padding
um but those padding values assume
monospace
so yeah
why do I have this is it in code
formatting
code formatting yep code formatting
okay
this is with the new this is just some
picture of old stuff
that's new but italic in text I thought
it's kind of I I liked what was going on
in nks and just tried italic here I
didn't like it for writing code
but in text it's interesting
and in the case that you're using a mono
or a uh Sarah or a sand spot in text
it's going to be helpful
here you know there's cases where your
Source Sans Pro and text and inline code
wouldn't be
wouldn't have much contrast
it's typically very convenient to make
single little supplied variables in
italic your content differentiate them
anymore
right I mean you mean you're saying
I'm sorry Michael are you saying you
don't like this because of some other
differentiation achieved by italics or
you're saying like this no I don't like
it because like like I would personally
I would make intentionally the A and the
K and the Lambda and the T italic
I see as so most of the code is not
italic but those guys
then we need another
way to indicate use of variables in some
sense things that change that I'm
pressing non-italic and it isn't doing
anything
I think that's set at the style sheet
level you I mean we could tweak the
style sheet I say okay fine
okay I want to find some other blocks of
code here let me let me just find a
random piece of code
um
I'm just going to paste the whole thing
in I have no idea what's in here
I don't think it's totally complicated
code but let's just um
let's just I'm going to go to the bottom
since I'd show this notebook especially
set up right Jeremy
the bottoms images yeah it'd be good to
put it there yeah oops well in this work
I just sort of a copy am I going crazy
what would help me read this
okay let me try reading it and by the
way I would you know there's one of the
problems that we still haven't solved is
the spoken form I mean like if I read
this out loud
I mean the service is helped by the fact
it has has some
you know custom line breaking
um
okay you have more examples everyone is
saying okay let me try this without
custom line breaking
time
God
by the way people haven't heard it here
I mean I haven't heard it
um something we're needing I I guess it
hasn't been communicated to anybody
here's a font character
that is the equivalent of
this
okay so it shows two characters
for use in documentation that's a tucked
you know a dash and a greater than sign
tucked but with a space are you aware of
that project John
no oh dear that's no good no this is the
very first I'm hearing of this I'm not
happy camper because this was in
documentation meeting today and I was
told you've been told about it
ah
okay
so the idea is that right now in
documentation we have this trade-off
between showing Dash greater than so
people know how to type it and showing
the more elegant Arrow that's what I'm
saying I say we get rid of that
trade-off and we just for documentation
purposes
we have a version of that character that
is you know visibly two characters but
is tucked to be elegant
okay
and we could do the same thing with with
um
uh you know with part brackets and
things like that
you know tuck em to increase Elegance
but still leave the um
uh
um
you know still leave the structure so to
speak
yeah
I don't know how that would work for
part brackets
um
well just make sure I mean I'm not sure
the question is really do people
oh maybe maybe you're just suggesting
and my concern was we can only make the
character so wide but maybe you're just
suggesting still two brackets but
they're not touching one another
exactly that's what I'm saying okay okay
I I get it now right it's just like make
it more elegant and give the indication
of something like the the full ligature
but don't actually go full ligature okay
is that a custom case that gets used
manually when needed or how do you how
do you invoke it I think it's just uh
yeah it's it's you would specify the
ligature in The Help style sheet okay
all right and if you copied and pasted
it into a default notebook then it would
use the other ligatures yeah okay which
just so that we're thinking about this
if you copy and pasted it it would use
the other ligatures which means the
appearance would kind of shift on you is
or I'm not I'm not worried about that
you're appreciating that okay yep I'm
not worried about that I think the
important thing is that you see it in
documentation and you know how to type
it
okay that's really all
you know like you see it in a heading
um you know this looks like kind of
weird 1988. and um we can do better than
that
um okay
let's see
everybody is pointing me to
oh there's an agenda for today
which is
wait a minute is that different from
this or is that
Jeremy's examples are in the bottom of
this
oh so so this is
I'm confused by this what what do you
want me to do here
basically you can run that notebook open
to get a new notebook and then apply it
but after after I create the palette
correct
yeah so this is just more samples that
you could
walk through exactly I see I see I see
okay
well I mean just in terms of
wait a minute is this this is an example
of it as well
I mean everything that notebook will
have it applied
to me this is a tweak but it's a good
tweak I mean what do other people think
you know this just makes all these
things look slightly better
I think
anybody
other people have comments on this
Michael what do you think I I think it
looks good
it's a little bit too black for me I
would prefer a slightly less foot rate
overall
so I agree I don't think we have it but
I agree completely like it's slightly
heavy
but if you go regular it's a pretty big
shift if you get rid of the the weight
change well and I mean
we are just looking at code here we're
not looking at it in the context of
narration if you get rid of the Bold
uh then just about the only thing left
that makes it pop as code is the color
which you know there may not be much of
in other words look much worse there too
yeah in other words if this is yeah
exactly if this is surrounded by text
you know you want the code to not look
like text
I I fully agree with you John but I was
more thinking if the piece of code that
Stephen has CG Moody Bake Off would be
10 times as big
then it would go over three pages then
in the middle Pages it would be big
blobs of black
because there are not much local
variables in some areas
I see
and let me be clear I I'm not saying I'm
attached to the Bold
what I'm saying is you want a
distinction
yes we can find other ways to make it
distinctive but it really should not go
around masquerading as narrative text
yeah see that that doesn't look bad I
mean that that
what other distinction could we imagine
making
I mean I don't really like any other
kind of you know let's take this and um
um
alcohol
no
well so let's try one thing here so I
mean you know you say it doesn't look
bad but comparing to the non-bold face
version that's below it uh well let's
try that let's try that yeah yeah that
that I'd be concerned about no that
doesn't work that just doesn't work
right yeah you understand my concern
yeah you're right you're right so the
question is what device can we get
and I was just going to try one thing
here
um I mean I think the main other thing
would be color yeah well right so that's
what I was going to try Jeremy do you
have a suggested you know place to go
for color I don't know
um how do I get how do I get even to the
the how do I get to the um
Chevron at the top right yeah
what is it what color wheel might work
color wheel
yeah that's weird
um
yeah
and if you move the the center part out
nothing changes right
ah okay oh oh okay now now move this
move the slider to the left that's the
problem
[Music]
uh what threw me off is that the slider
is oppositely directed from what I
expected
I expected black to be on the left
this doesn't have enough contrast for me
I know didn't work
yeah
Jeremy do you have a suggestion about a
color direct I mean something like this
is not except for the fact that blue is
very much a used color
I mean how do we go purple here
um
where do we go for purple Jeremy can we
go more towards the red yeah over there
yeah that's it
this isn't doing it for me
um
kind of fun actually it's less black
well and remember what I said toward the
end of the last meeting
um which is that uh
when you look at what when people are
putting code onto slides uh that
oftentimes they're they're going with
very bold colors on slides
at least that's my experience
I mean I don't think I couldn't stand
writing everyday code yeah that's where
I'm stuck it's just uh couldn't imagine
using this day to day
and then the the color for numbers seems
crazy
so okay but but so are we imagining all
right so
what you've got right now to me is a
tweak on what we currently have it's an
improvement tweak and it's one that I
think many people if we if we put it in
into production
um
uh
you know
probably nobody would even notice
we might guess
people would I mean just like you know
if you quizzed me on the difference
between documentation formatting and
this writing and so on I just wouldn't
even notice it and
the fact that I don't notice it
does not mean it doesn't make it easier
for me to read it
uh
But but so what is that what is our
thought that we put something we change
the default
I mean I'm just trying to think what it
would feel like okay so here let me just
try
you know and by the way we we could have
you know slightly brighter colors for
some of these things although I'm not
sure
how does this feel
yeah I mean I wouldn't know the
difference between this so this is just
a a more slightly more elegant version
of what I would normally
you know what I would normally be doing
here
I don't think I would I think I barely
noticed the difference except that
why did the skirt that that's much more
compact there why is that
hmm
what was it oh is it because of lack of
monospacing
why did this get more compact yeah
yeah that's exactly why
because there was otherwise a monospace
space here whereas here it's just a a
kind of a I bet it's the commas I bet
the commas are mono spaced so the commas
have lots of air around them in the
source serif or the source sentence
yeah but we don't have that and we go
and we and we think we don't want that I
mean why do we not want more comma
spaces well we didn't tweak the the font
itself we just tweaked a setting in the
font but we didn't change anything any
of the geometry
it can it can be tweaked we just didn't
do that yet
so that's we could fix that
okay Avery is asking about this purple
let me just try
um
how do I enter a color
can I do it from here how do I just type
in a color
um the yeah show expression or option
inspector
well
but CMYK is an interesting choice
I cannot tell that I mean
hold on
so this
if we so first of all what happens if we
got unbold
kind of looks bad
okay let's go bold and then let's go
let's get rid of that color
I mean this certainly gets rid of the
overwhelming blackness
I'm not sure that it's
an everyday kind of code color
it's not terrible actually Michael what
do you think
I would probably stick respect for my
personal use
you could try cutting the black just
slightly like a gray level 0.1 to see if
that helps
foreign
that's above
I mean I wonder what happens if we go
I'm I'm at 125 here let me just see
I think it does help this gray level 0.1
does help
okay
and it also is interesting because it
would potentially allow an accent color
that could be helpful for some of the
things we're trying to do
all right so
I mean I think it'd be worth just trying
to switch this on as a default and see
whether people internally you know in
version 13 3 builds or something freak
out about it
Lucas is commenting that they have a a
different
they have a slightly grayish blue for
the system context which makes custom
stuff pop out more
um
okay
I'll notice suggesting
making the background of the cell black
well that's going to look terrible
I mean that's you know we obviously have
to solve this for dark mode but that's a
separate thing
okay all right so let's let's Okay so I
think we've got here
I mean these commas look like they've
got plenty of space there's some issue
with commas Maybe
I say we try we try making this a
default and see what happens comments
from people
default what do you mean by default
for code
no for input natural code I mean I I
meant for input okay but it's a
different story for all notebooks yeah
I'm sorry I thought we were talking
about
special notebooks not everything
well I just think it's so hard to even
distinguish this I mean I can barely
tell the difference okay but I think
it's somewhat better so I'm asking the
question I mean you know between this
and this
there really is so little difference yet
this is slightly nicer to read so why
not try just using it so this is how you
sneak in the back door over my
objections over my my proportionally
based objections
well I don't know which is we have six
meetings where we're not talking about
default notebooks and then you just say
let's do this for default notebooks but
I just think that it is not that
different
I mean do you okay I just want to
understand from you if you look at this
versus this
does this jump out at you as oh this is
horrible
I think it's horrible horrible for what
purpose
I mean if I'm doing custom tabbing then
I'm doing code I'm not doing you know
regular notebook
you know
input cells
wait what's going to say I would like to
see a larger piece of Code cast with
custom indentation uh where things have
to line up and I have Clique and other
characters and I want to see how they
are that
okay well we should do that
I mean
I think yes I agree I mean I'm just I'm
just saying I mean I don't know how we
put this in and have anybody use it I
mean it's a good start I suppose to have
um
uh
you know we could just have this be
I don't know where we put this John
so people would actually use it
so we don't simply have a repeat of what
we've had for so many years where people
like publish books where they put code
in Korea fonts and so on
John what's your suggestion for how to
enable this
for the purpose of writing books we
figure out what was love for writing
books no no no no not for writing books
I'm talking about people who
are
trying to make notebooks that I'm not
talking about people who say I'm going
to write a book I'm going to take three
months to might do the setup for it I'm
talking about somewhat everyday stuff
I I don't I just don't get the objection
that's the point I don't get you know to
me the difference between here and here
is not that great except this looks a
bit more elegant
I mean it'd be one thing if if this was
just dramatically different but I just
don't see it I don't get what what
feature you're seeing in this which
you're not seeing in this
help me to understand that I don't I
just don't understand
well I mean for one thing
I mean
you know we got to the point where the
bold face was the only thing that caused
it to pop so
so what what do outputs look like
outputs look look the same as inputs
well that's a good question that's a
good question do the outputs suddenly
become okay they look exactly like
narration okay that's a good question
let's look for that let's look at that
I mean we're talking about this for
inputs we have not talked about it for
outputs will it have it for output cells
here
and this would not be gray
um there's some tweaks I made the input
that won't flow into output
like line spacing
the operator there's much black I'm
surprised those aren't gray John is that
on purpose
uh that's on purpose okay
I think well I don't remember so John
you're raising that's a perfectly valid
objection okay
because I don't think this looks
particularly good
I mean part of the problem is I don't
you know
I'm getting old my vision is getting
worse I I I do not want to struggle to
distinguish the code from the texts
that's why it's why that's the first
thing I raised when we were talking
about this okay but I don't think
there's a huge problem in distinguishing
this text from this code is that but it
but but I mean before there were two big
indicators we removed one of them the
other one is still
mostly sufficient and when I say the two
big indicators I mean bold facing and
monospacing yep
okay but if that's your point I mean
that's good to know that's your point
it's not something to do with tabbing I
agree that this is not adequate
that distinction is is kind of
questionable
I mean there there will also be issues
of people who you know expect
monospacing for other reasons but it's I
I want code that looks like code
um
you know I I admit that there's you know
it's a combination of functional and
cultural expectations but okay but but I
don't think this breaks the cultural
expectations here I agree that this
doesn't make it
I think that for some people it will
absolutely break the cultural
expectations okay let's try it let's put
it in and see what happens I'm I'm I'm
expecting pitchforks okay well fine
that that that's it's good to expect
pitchforks if it turns out that nobody
notices that's a good piece of data
it's like the famous you know shrinking
blob thing where
basically we put it in and essentially
nobody noticed except that they didn't
lose that place and and you know when
they typed
um but look what about the outfit if we
put it in could we add a preference so
they could change it at least
well so here here's here here's the
problem
when you add that preference the people
who care most will turn it off and and
will never hear from them again because
they've already given us up as being
lunatics that that they don't want to
and they want no part of this yeah okay
fine but but I I okay if we can get
somewhere where we can turn this on that
would be a good start
okay so I can try it at least if nobody
else wants to try it
wfr
yeah possibly
all right I didn't catch what you said a
wfr function oh wfr okay I'm not keen on
that
not you know that I'm I I
mean honestly you know I never use a
non-default style sheet
except when it is part of a whole
complicated workflow
all right but listen listen we've got a
real problem here which is what to do
with the outputs
okay
is that coming out and that's that's in
the that's is that in in the new source
Sans yeah that's the new font I expect
more problems with wait wait wait wait
wait wait is this not models this looks
monospaced it's not no
I can't even tell I can't tell
John yeah well now right side by side
it's clear yeah the choice of content in
there makes it more difficult to tell
yeah uh it's because all of the
characters in there are full width
except for the one and the one is
sitting there by itself
okay so the square root of five looks
kind of funky I'm not sure that graying
down the square roots is the right thing
yeah
this doesn't look absolutely horrible
though
wait would the gray carry through how
would the gray get into output it can't
right
um you mean the op the operator the
structure well the odd that option that
point one isn't soaking into the output
I think that's just the way it looks
okay I mean this looks pretty decent to
me
well so Jeremy it depends on if you
applied it to the input style or the
standard form style I think it just went
into the cell it didn't no I didn't add
it anywhere Steven just tweaked the cell
yeah
oh uh that's sorry sorry that's right
yes I I
what
sorry I have to remind myself what code
I gave you uh I guess it was to the
whole notebook so it would probably be
yeah any standard form
will do what uh we'll we'll gray down
we'll we'll grade The Operators just the
way that I expect it because it was
easier to spec it that way so this will
grade The Operators
yes okay which is what it seems to be
doing yeah uh but but that's just I
wasn't thinking about it when I when I
gave you that setting that could in
principle be you know turned on or off
on a per style basis I have to say I'm
not horrified I was I'm a lot less
horrified than I initially for a moment
was
with these um
can we get if Michael do you have
anything with Greeks that would show off
I'm worried about the font weight
comparison of source Sands with Greeks
just yeah or or you know or you know
just like you know take the CG multi-way
graph definition and wrap a hold around
it
it doesn't look horrible but I'm I'm not
convinced that that's a great Greek font
for this I mean you know we may be able
to find another Greek font wait a minute
this one here what do you want me to do
oh yeah yeah just wrap hold around it
I mean what am I supposed to see here
the operator is gray or not
well what you're supposed to see is now
this is starting to look an awful lot
like texts
just text
yeah
except it doesn't
the only thing that's really holding it
apart from the text is the white space
and the operators
that's
starting to get pretty subtle and pretty
dependent on what the actual content of
of that guy was I agree
I agree I mean look in in the case where
we put in something like you know we put
fold in here and I don't even know how
to how do I I do command nine now
oh I see now you're italicizing that
well yeah I tweaked it if it weren't
italic I think it this is roughly what
we do in your eiwl book it's a semi-bold
for inline code
why can't we use semibold here by the
way
it's not bold that's but there's no it
will go slightly thinner it would be
better
that way by the way is not just here
it's what we use in default right now
in in 13 too
all right just for my I mean you know
it's like distinguishing math
I mean
yeah that's not usable for General
output
looks quite nice though
um
well so what what is the issue here I
mean we're looking at
that's wild
that looks not good
well it's not at all used to it I mean
it looks a little bit more like ordinary
math in a sense
okay
where are we going from here
I think we should you know have a way of
setting this and you tell me what you
want to do for how that's set up John
a way so that I can routinely set a
notebook to use these new Styles both of
them for input and output
what's the right way to set that well if
it's only in the Prototype build there
will be
fewer pointy objects uh being shoved in
my direction
yeah I don't tend to use the type of
production stuff though
um I mean is that just some switch we
could put in somewhere
is that what will we do if we're doing
this for actual users what would we do
we put it in the format menu we put it
in style environment or something
I mean we can certainly make a version
of default dot MB that would overload
your
you know uh uh your establishes so why
not just me but I want something where
we where you set something and just say
set this
but it's got to be able to be sticky
which this is not by default right what
about default screen environment well
it'd have to have a backup in case it's
not there
well but there isn't a default screen
environment
well working is default right now but
it's I don't know how that works oh I
see
the I I'll have to double check this but
I think that you could set a global
environment that wouldn't get saved into
your notebooks
um
okay
yeah I mean but that's some crazy thing
with the option inspector which is not a
user level thing
right
but I mean you know anything in the
option inspector is one line of code
which means it can be a wfr or whatever
you want
um
but we can try it I suppose I mean
that's the beginning now although of
course wfr isn't I mean you know
the uh
sorry in in terms of deploying it to
users uh are you talking about
13-2 users because that means deploying
a new version of default.mb to 13 to
users who want this and that's a little
bit it's possible but it's a little
trickier
okay well I mean that would be nice
because I'm certainly going to use 13
too that's I I I I I think basically
it's something we'd want to do as a
packlets
um okay fine because uh let's figure it
out because any other mechanism would
end up potentially causing problems with
13 1 13 3 et cetera et cetera packlet we
can we can make it only work on thirteen
two
okay let's get a solution where we can
deploy this at least for me in a nice
smooth way and
let's see how it feels like what it
feels like and including for output
okay and you know
I I may very well come back and say it's
hopeless it's not working
but let's find out
okay Jeremy are you are there things
you're gonna refactor before I would uh
look at this
I want to put in the point one for input
and then
I think that's it I could look at output
which I haven't taken much of a look at
so yeah why don't you look at that I've
got another question why are we not
doing any syntax coloring and output
um
because
uh I mean it's an intentional decision I
know uh you know syntax coloring
is to help you
read code and you're not you're not
reading output in the same way that
you're reading code I know except in a
case that's what I mean
right except we have patterns and things
in the output except where the output is
code
my question is if we're not centralized
coloring look in a case like this we
don't want to send test called things
but we wouldn't anyway there'd be
nothing since I scored here an input
right
uh aside from the operator coloring that
we're doing
um
the uh
uh there would be context coloring
so the Alphas
would be context colored
okay
but nothing else I mean like this
doesn't have any color contrast colors I
mean any colors at all but you're saying
if I replaced well that X and any any
Global context variable with no
assignment the X's the alphas all those
would be would get the global coloring
you know the blue that we use for Global
coloring
it's barely noticeable
go ahead Michael if there's anything
which for me makes output not easy
usable it's the missing of string codes
especially if I read a two megabyte XML
file and then inspect it I always have
to make it input to
extract the relevant Parts uh but I
think you will also agree that the the
the the the barn door is open on that
one there isn't really yes yes anything
you can do about that I'm just saying
kind of if there's anything that would
be yeah well I mean the only issue is is
a hover effect
but even that I'm not convinced about
but I mean the the hover effect would
would have deleterious effects yeah okay
fine fine I I mean for example like a
manipulate you know they're there are
more places than you might think of
where the quotes are hiding and it's a
good thing uh I understand what about
what about um uh when you click
what about when you click
sorry what's your question
um actually Sandra's making a good point
which is if in your output you've syntax
you've used style to color something and
then syntax coloring comes in and and
and Stomps on it that's no good yeah
yeah
it's a good reason for not syntax color
the output
I mean
there's a certain argument okay so
Michael is saying he has to switch to
input form
to see string quotes yes
I mean
there's a certain argument like your
piece of code that you just said is a
perfect example for it
which piece of code
the the little one you are this one with
Mr Holt I see okay yeah how do you know
that today on the bedding obviously you
know it's absolutely hopeless right it's
hopeless I agree
so
you know to me rather than switching to
input form which blows everything up
it would be nice to be able to switch
this output to a form that is kind of
output input so to speak
I mean imagine we had another Style
that was
you know suitable for these cases where
the output you get you really want to
think of as input
is that a common is that a common enough
case
yes but then people click into the
output and make it into an input
well I understand that's what I do most
of the time for this except that
I mean you know we've got a cell gear
menu coming and that's a place where we
could put some more of this the stuff
like you know show you know we could say
show as input or something or show with
you know
seems to me that that would be a place
which people would actually you know
after a short while learn that you could
do that
seems helpful to me
that I mean I could also sorry I had
someone chatted me about the next
meeting I'm missing I didn't I didn't
catch your suggestion my suggestion is
that in the cell gear menu we have show
as input or something some such other
thing which isn't switched to input form
but just show I don't know show with
input regalia or whatever you want to
call it
seems like a good suggestion to me
and that way you get string quotes you
get syntax coloring you get all these
things if you want it and you don't
otherwise now
I mean what is the advantage to having
that be a separate thing over just
converting it to an input cell
um well how do you okay fine we could
have something that says convert to
input cell I don't even know how to do
that how do I do that but I mean it's
the same thing as if you typed into it
okay so if I do command nine I can do I
do that yeah yes okay fine I mean if
that was in the cell gear menu that
would probably be enough that's probably
just just fine that's very perfectly
sufficient
Michael
it's a version of what I do right now
right but having that in the cell gear
menu seems worthwhile
okay let's let's take a quick moment
okay so I think we've got a plan here
let's take a quick moment to look at
these um
uh where were they
this code kind of looks fairly nice like
this I have to say
boy as much of a Panama relevant code
here okay all right let's look at this
this is okay are these mock-ups like
like yeah yeah this is just Photoshop
okay
I we had looked at these a little bit
and
agreed they probably weren't that
helpful except maybe on
the focus
definitely not wild coding no no no
definitely not a default did I miss
something I'm not remembering a
discussion around this
yeah we talked about underlining and
kind of emphasizing the basically
embedments kind of these the nestings
okay maybe I was just so not behind the
idea that I threw it out which included
adjusting the Baseline which you gave
some code for right
but this is not meant as static
oh okay I yes I remember the adjusting
the Baseline okay okay yeah
I I forgot about suggesting underlining
that's what I forgot
um
I don't think this particular code is so
useful to do that with yeah I mean I
would like to see it but if we have do
we have code that can do underlining
no I mean not easily
we only have one method of underlining
unless you're gonna turn it like into a
graphic or uh another weird what do you
mean we have a message okay so I mean
but but
couldn't we just make this a box
that has a you know
uh you know a an overscript box or
something well yes you could do you
could do underscript boxes but then it's
not properly editable
um
but I don't care for purposes of seeing
what it looks like that will be enough
in this case Stephen it wasn't clear for
me what to do with parents and
um curly brackets as far as underlines
go and I still don't know it seems like
it'd be a mess if I included them so I
didn't
so this is function nesting but nothing
else yeah which is also what the what
the yellowing does is functioning and in
the end I thought include the head I
think these don't have it but it seemed
more useful to start with the head and
end with the closing square bracket I
agree with you yeah
so the bottom is another experiment so
if you scroll down a little bit some
highlighting with the same concept and
some different types of underlining
without all the layers
God yeah
I can't tell anything from you yeah I
know I know
look the thing that would be easier to
tell is nested boxes
let me let me just offer a suggestion
here I mean I just uh you know an
example
okay I'm going to show you an extreme
version of nested boxes I'm sure I've
got code to do this
uh let me see what it is
um
there are some extreme nested boxes in
here
um
okay see those nested boxes
yeah
you can definitely tell what groups with
what
even when it's dotted it's hard
I think it probably works well in a
single line could you imagine line
wrapping though
I think it breaks as soon as you get
three or four lines of code totally
certain about that well let's find out I
mean we've got we can just click to copy
this creature
oh my goodness sake really oh I picked
the absolutely worst line to do that
with
wow okay
all right now let's try oh gosh well I
mean that has both color and
all right let's try a bigger one of
these
um
uh come on I've got definitely have
these
okay
let's try this
I mean it may not even alignment
properly I don't know
actually it's interesting because I'm
actually now using
okay that's pretty hopeless
I don't even know what it did there
is it are we missing stuff off to the
right scroll to the right I think it's
probably one big long yeah yeah I mean
this is humorously bad but I mean this
is also a very worst case
situation
and by the way this isn't even
oh I see this is only showing the
rewrites that can happen yeah never mind
this is this is only showing some subset
of the things
but to get a box that would clip and
then flow to the next line
this is going to be you know
you won't yeah I know and then you have
to decide whether yeah I I think the
majority of cases we haven't went such a
feature is one has a reasonable large
piece of code say longer than four lines
that one didn't fight oneself and wants
to understand what it does and it cannot
reform it it's basically like double
clicking more and more is very useful
but it is kind of an expensive operation
to do yes exactly look I'm getting used
to this yellow thing and the fact that
we now have it be bright yellow is
really good
I was a community post here does
somebody have maybe you can just point
me to the the raw thing on the community
here it won't have the right styling
stuff from Jeremy though that's why I
uploaded it let's see
okay let's take a look
um what's your point that this basically
looks pretty good
yeah with the spacing and everything I
think it looks really good
well I mean this little things went
wrong with the spacing here but that
might have been in the source
I mean this is code though
and these rules are getting applied to
the code as well
as opposed to just input
you know what I'm saying because this
here
right if I make that
just code though or is it uh
initialization cell
oh it's an initialization cell how do I
how do I get rid of that I do control
eight
yeah okay
okay so it wasn't in fact code but what
is code is command H right is that
correct
yes
yes in this case not getting well what
did it do it did something really weird
here
oh I see it's left the fonts but it it
got rid of the spacing
that right
but we clearly need to figure out what
what's happening with code here keep
that in mind John because there was no
intent for that to flow into like the
package out of there but I I don't know
how to structure it so it doesn't Okay
Stephen I uh sorry I was slightly
distracted because I was just as an
amusing experiment
uh
um I'm throwing something in the chat
here
uh you can oops sorry nope wrong thing
wrong thing sorry
let me try again
um
there okay so uh
uh like after your resource function
paste what I just threw in the chat
which reason sorry after like the
combinator Evolve resource function yeah
that one okay at the end just paste what
I threw in there for you
this here yes
wow
well in this particular case this is
quite useful
I mean it saves from absolute absolute
hopeless horror
there's there's a little bug in my code
that causes it to skip a few levels but
that gets you the general idea though I
mean for this particular use case it's
lovely can I dismiss your hold from
above exactly what I was going to try
yeah
where is that
what's this yeah let's see see
can you find it
no I'm just what do you mean can I find
it you mean the code in the in the text
yes I can find the code in the text I'm
just that's not what wasn't my problem
okay this do I want to make this hold
and then I want to say slash and then I
want to give you a thing here
oh uh and well because overscript box
doesn't want to break lines so that's
that's why it's all in one line
it's not so helpful if it we can't
um
I don't know how we really see something
like this work usefully I mean maybe I
can just pick out
uh
that's somewhat short
actually I take it back that's not a bug
in my code if uh that's the the the gaps
are quite yeah intentional it turns out
yeah
okay let's understand this so is it
possible to make your code include the
heads
is that easy to do is this is because
um yes
yes I can do that I mean this thing here
it's just confusing to me because it
doesn't include that head
yeah
um
so
that's a pretty easy
modification
uh I think uh
um
see
uh Sanders comedy like the single thick
line that was
this one here
and the question would be you know could
you make that darker I doubt that will
work but it's conceivable so the idea of
that one is if you got used to the
colors you would know by color The Nest
levels so if that was right but what
sequence of colors are people used to
I even have a hard time for remembering
you know right now
I started with just straight Hue but
then it then I threw in a big green so
the greens like the in that middle one
would be your your focus well you know
the human I don't think most people even
know that
I mean I think that I could imagine
I mean we could try
and and the problem is it's kind of like
a barber polling type thing because you
never know how deep you're going to go
right
but it's constant no so if you go from
Focus Point outwards
then you know your second level nesting
is always the same color your third
level is the same
I don't understand how you can guarantee
that because you don't have the colors
you could go 100 Levels down
but you go inside out you know you start
your color starts with your focus point
and then spreads
outer outwards so like okay okay I I
just threw in the chat it's an extremely
ugly implementation because I'm trying
to turn around something quickly but I
think that will work
and of course it underlines even even
the hold which you wouldn't want but uh
that's what you get for making me write
code in two minutes five seconds right
foreign
what would happen if these had
some kind of color gradient probably
probably it's hopeless because
again you never know how deep you're
going to go and you know the fact that
the you know the depths are uneven I
mean it it looks like a bug
you know well we talked about maybe just
if this was on demand you know based on
where your cursor is focused you'd only
see one pyramid at a time
yeah yes yeah if it's selection based
then yes that's true
I'm not worried about it looking like a
bug people will get used to that very
quickly and I think one could avoid that
problem by just putting a a small
background color behind all of this
stuff
I don't think that would be a problem
the gapping
question is is this useful
looking at this
you can follow heads pretty closely I
think you can actually
I mean you can get some idea you know I
can't tell you what is this line versus
this line very easily
but if you start in the center and then
you work yourself out then that's a
useful thing and in general just kind of
following the heads backwards
okay what is useful here what's useful
here is the stepping down
why is this stepping down useful the
stepping down is useful because it is
easier to see that
than to see somebody switch the video on
the
um
sorry about that no no problem
I single line did the stepping down too
though if you look at that and you're
just thinking of you know starting
inside and then stepping down
you get the same thing
sorry say that again try that the single
line version really quick and if you're
just what's the single line version you
mean you're you're one of the colors the
colorful rainbow if you start on the
inside and then you're stepping down
you're just following the lines right to
see function heads
I agree
yeah so John is it possible for you to
just put a random color into these
different levels
uh into for the levels to differ from
one another that's not so easy uh that's
like that'll take me more each line just
here I'm gonna I'm gonna do whatever but
but coloring them all the same color is
easy but color
I'm going to suggest this maybe I'm
crazy yeah
see
um
right like this
oops
wait wait a minute what do I do wrong
sorry where
um not color black color
oh I need to do this with not with style
what do I do here
uh style box style box
and you probably should put font color
Arrow
okay but where's my bracketing wrong
uh one more bracket after the random
color
yeah guy I just made the same change
locally and it and it works for me
okay but those colors look terrible
um how do I make brighter dot I mean
what do I do I say darker of this comma
0.7
oh great
bold
that's useless okay so if I say front
weight Arrow bold
better
post colors are surprisingly unhelpful
I mean frankly I would have expected for
something like this that you might want
like more transparents
what do you mean well I mean do you
really want the colors to uh
uh you're trying to prevent the colors
from popping by making them darker uh no
I'm not trying to do that I'm trying to
make them visible either they were not
visible they were just like oh yeah well
well
I mean yeah white or something but
the
I mean I I I would have gone for like a
more transparent color is something with
opacity I admit that this with with the
Bolding this is not so invisible yeah
actually this is not completely
functionally useless looks kind of ugly
and weird but it's not functionally
useless if you try and Trace what's
where
it would probably help if this thing
here had a little hook on it that
connects it up to that edge form which
is so I I mean there are a couple things
that cause this I did this because I
thought it would be amusing to look at
but I think there are a couple of ways
in which this quickly breaks down first
of all
um I don't see how
yeah I think it's difficult to for this
to communicate information across line
breaks uh well with with color I think
it's not impossible
but still difficult you're looking at
things that are quite far apart from
each other and even if you're lining up
radically different colors you're still
doing some lining up if you understand I
know I know I know
um and then the other issue is that uh
you know in order for this to be usable
and if it's going to be at every level
uh you're just throwing out your line
spacing you know line spacing is now
just a random
I don't know whether that's a terrible
thing or not I mean it's not the case
that this is something I you know this
is not on by default by any means
okay so there are a couple of different
options here one is
you know you select
an anchor point and then you go out from
there I think that's less useful than
this Global thing I have to say
I think it's very useless in a large
piece of code you want to understand a
certain segment you select an anchor and
look there okay multi-click all the time
not having to multi-click but get the
same out of it would be useful okay so
hold on hold on hold on we've got two
different problems we're trying to solve
here
one is the global view of the code which
I claim this is not as useless as you
think
if if one was actually trying to
understand this code without clicking so
to speak
you have to acknowledge limits you
cannot go to infinite depth on this
um
so yeah at some point you have to give
up
that point
um
I mean you could say we can do up to
five levels up to ten levels you know
pick a number but you have to pick a
finite number
not just finite wait wait wait wait wait
wait what would it actually do if you
went too far I mean taking this as an
example
this is about as deeply nested but
that's very locally nested
right the difficulty is well I mean I
mean imagine you know Nest f of x 100 or
something like that
it was the
no no you made the same mistake I made
first time up to the slap slash not the
slash Dot
the first time I sent you something and
I said no that's the wrong thing it's
because I went to the slash dot as well
so you and I made the same mistake
it's on the previous line or yeah or you
can add the slash slash yeah
uh yeah yeah that'd be fine
what are the nose uh that's a that's
probably a bug I'm pretty sure it's a
bug in my code I just yeah bye
but you get the idea of why we have to
have limits
entertaining
but what would the limiting look like
the limiting would just be that you cut
off
I mean you could go somehow hyperbolic
and you could you know or something you
could make those things closer and
closer together oh by the way I just
found the bug in my code if if and I can
point you right where it is if you go
back to the definition of code color
uh I put an extra comma after uh mid mid
comma Comma just uh delete one of those
commas there you go
help oh
really
why would that have failed
oh oh oh oh no no no it's like I
introduced uh a cycle which my extra
comma accidentally worked around in uh
the replace all repeated
um
okay
I mean here
well it's more useful than it was just
with brackets
I mean this is a very hard to read thing
should wrap this up in a second but but
uh
I mean what I'm suggesting is these
things get closer together so you don't
have a stack This Tall
is what I'm saying so if you have
something where the distance between
these things goes you know you you could
have it limit to a fixed it's like
Michael at least knows what I'm talking
about like in the pike array disc for
example yeah
um
no I mean whatever strategy you use to
try to merge it's always going to you
know it's always going to eventually
either fail or throw information out
eventually it's you know
this is a failure if you try to squeeze
it in it's going to throw effectively
well that's right it is it is but I
don't think it's so bad I don't think it
will throw out in other words I think it
will show you the stuff you care about
because it will show you is there a
connection between this and that you
won't that won't be lost
probably I don't know it would require
some thought to but I I think well I
mean I mean the question is how far do
you need to see that connection I don't
know I mean but we can you know once
you've gone 10 heads out
uh dude was it it's so important anymore
I don't know but I do think
I I think it could be important to see
that globally but I think that there's a
way to do it so that we so that the
detail of okay here's the information
you don't need that was the 18th level
ahead
you need to know that was there was a
connection between here and there but
you don't care whether it was on the
18th level or the 12th level so by the
way it should be pointed out that
um in user assistance we had a a
proposal for uh from NOAA for a uh uh
kind of a uh you know an exploration
type interface you know where you would
hover and it would do these things on
Hover and
um I I I I think that proposal is
maybe a sensible I mean I don't remember
where we left it it may be on ice for
now
um maybe we should bring that back to
this this discussion
that may be better I mean this this
static one I agree with you it's a
little bit over oh I I think it could be
useful
by the way we should make a WR out of
this thing that we you just you just
created
it'll be useful well maybe maybe I'll
make a version that works then
um there's a few comments on the live
stream and then we should wrap it up
here uh
Lucas asked what about just highlighting
all the heads wrapped around the current
cursor position
that's like Dynamic highlighting but all
the way up
yeah so that's this
and we've talked about in user
assistance we've talked about doing that
with Dynamic highlighting and I think
both you and I have agreed that we have
concerns that it would be confusing and
not as informational as as you might
hope
well it's worth an experiment I mean to
take this now that we have a bright
yellow there and just have like a tinge
of yellow on the outer ones
well I mean the two obvious things to do
uh from from my perspective thing number
one would be uh uh you know applying you
know levels of trans you know increasing
levels of transparency on the way out
proposal number two would be
radically different colors the rainbow
proposal no
I don't think that's useful I I think
the thing I'd like to see is just the
inner1 bright yellow
all outer ones lighter yellow
well I I think the farther out the
lighter it should be okay
yeah I I don't think you want to treat
you know two or three levels out or you
know two levels out the same as three
levels out I really don't yeah okay fine
fine we should try this it's a good idea
we should try it
because I don't know what would it
highlight here I mean it's going to be
well just I mean just click in the word
graph and you'll see what it would
highlight next
just you know start wherever you want
and then whatever it's highlighting
click on the Highlight thing and you'll
see the next thing out that we'll
highlight so now click on graph
and now you'll see the next thing that
will get highlighted which is the width
this would be useful
this would be in that particular case
it's a quite shallow
this would be quite useful
well um
all right this will be useful I've
proposed it before but you and I were
constantly fighting on this because
I find that the trick of just clicking
the yellow and I know the back is useful
I've never done that
this will be useful to click here and
see sort of lightest stuff out so long
as it's light enough that you really
aren't confused by what's what who could
you delay it John and have them kind of
fade in like sequentially
yeah I'm quite skeptical of of that
I think the little explosion as it goes
out yeah yeah right no I mean that would
be very helpful to be able to see that
um
let's see click about it now highlights
the other bracket what if it just
highlighted
what if I just highlighting the other
bracket underlining it but for that
chunk I don't think you'd like that
because as soon as you do underlying
you've got to move statcoder you've got
to move things around and that's going
to be really ugly highlighting is doable
in place
all right we should wrap it up here this
was very helpful we should have another
one of these but let's get some things
implemented and let's get I really like
to see this multi-head
thing that seems useful to me
it seems really quite useful
all right anything else to say for this
meeting
oh okay good stuff and thank you to
people on the live stream for lots of
useful comments here I thought there'd
be useful comments on this topic
um
all right see you guys soon bye for now